in modern scholarship on the early
history of Islam the first hundred years
has always often viewed as a big
question mark the life of the Prophet
Muhammad and his followers and the years
following was only written down a
hundred years later at least sometimes
200 years later in biography is known as
serie and in the hadith literature and
this literature was also written by
Muslims themselves making them subject
to bias and such things because of this
much of the hadith and the biography
literature is viewed in a skeptical
light by scholars but the jurist not on
this and there's a whole spectrum of
people some were completely critical of
all hadith others who accept it as
complete truth and then a various number
of people in between those extremes but
if you accept the notion that the hadith
from a historical critical perspective
are unreliable sources for knowing the
early history of Muhammad's movements
then we aren't left with much at all
so is it completely hopeless to try to
reimagine what this period might have
looked like the one actually happens
well maybe but probably not there are
other sources primarily two other
sources which are usually considered to
be authentic and contemporary to the
life of the Prophet Muhammad the first
of these is actually the Quran itself
there have been fragments of the Quran
found that date back to at least shortly
after Muhammad's death or even when he
lived that show a sort of impressive
amount of continuity with the text we
have today the second is a document
referred to as the constitution of
Medina and if it is indeed from the time
of the prophets then it can tell us some
really interesting things about the
movement that be later came to call
Islam
[Applause]
the constitution of Medina is thought to
have been authored at the instruction of
the Prophet Muhammad himself shortly
after his arrival in the city of Medina
then known as a3 some background context
is necessary here according to Muslim
tradition the Prophet Muhammad received
his first revelation and started his
preaching in the year 610 when he was
still living in Mecca as a result of
this he was strongly oppressed and
persecuted along with this growing group
of followers by the ruling haurache
tribe who ruled the city and saw his
message of one God as both heresy and a
political threat the persecution
continued for many years and came to its
peak in 622 when an attempt was made on
Muhammad's life shortly before this
muhammad had received a message from the
citizens of a nearby city called Yathrib
who promised to give him and his
followers shelter if he was to act as a
political mediator between the tribes of
the city and these tribes were sort of
bitterly fighting with each other so
Muhammad EIN his followers emigrated to
year 3 bin the year 622 which became
known as the harem which means simply
the migration and this is also the start
of the Muslim calendar a sort of Year
Zero once he arrived in Medina I was
faced with a situation where he was now
the political leader of a number of
different tribes some of which were
Jewish tribes and other which follows
the the old pagan Arabian religion and
some were of course his own followers
what we would refer to as Muslims today
so this is the context in which the
document was authored in an attempt to
create a kind of I won't say state's but
a political unit a political order in a
city where that was sort of averaged by
a conflict between different tribes the
authenticity of this document as at
least partly stemming from this period
is agreed upon by many scholars both
Muslim and non-muslim the author Tom
Holland the one who is not spider-man
often viewed as part of the very
skeptical revisionist school once stated
that the constitution of Medina is
accepted by even the most suspicious of
scholars as deriving from the time of
Muhammad and while this is a bit of
hyperbole in my opinion it is true that
many scholars do accept it as authentic
Frederick M Denny affirms
the same point by saying that there is
little doubt among scholars that it is
authentic and that it like the Quran is
intimately connected with Muhammad's
thoughts and activity some aspects that
speak against its authenticity is that
it were the earliest examples of it are
from the biographies of the venetie
which was much like the other hadith and
biographies written down a hundred and
fifty years after the Prophet Muhammad
actually died and so by that logic it
should be viewed and the same skeptical
light as the other hadith and syrahs on
the other hand the the content of the
document itself sometimes speaks for its
authenticity for example the very
negative way that the Quraysh
is portrayed suggests a sort of an early
origin for it and in my opinion the very
you could say liberal or tolerant
attitudes that the the document shows
towards unbelievers or non-muslims like
Jews and possibly even polytheists would
be strange for a later period it would
be weird for someone in 750 in a more
sort of developed Islamic civilization
or Empire to show such leniency towards
Jews or unbelievers in general as this
document does in the book Muhammad at
Medina the scholar W Montgomery watt
writes that no later falsify writing
under the Umayyads or abbasids would
have included non-muslims in the Ummah a
point we will get to soon would have
retained the article against the Quraysh
and would have given Muhammad so
insignificant a place moreover the style
is archaic and certain points such as
the use of believers instead of Muslims
in most articles belong to the earlier
medinan period there are four main
groups referred to in the document the
first is the Muharram or more a mean
meaning immigrants and believers
respectively and which are both words to
describe the followers of Muhammad most
of which came from Mecca in the sort of
immigration the Hegira
this is the group that we today would
call Muslims but there are reasons to
believe that this is a much later term
indeed the document does use the word
Muslim which creates certain problems
with that theory the second are the
various Jewish tribes that lived in the
city and thirdly there are the nan
is basically polytheists who lived in
the city and lastly there are the
Quraysh who were mostly used to mean the
Meccans and thereby the enemies of this
group the actual content of the document
is an attempt to create a social and
political unit or covenant under which
the people of the city is to live under
Mohammed and Suzan agrees followers are
to be the rulers of this group in this
city but the documents or the covenant
includes most people living in yathreb
at the time so let's dive into the
document itself for a bit sit the
document begins as follows this is a pre
script of Muhammad the prophet and
messenger of God to operate between the
faithful and the followers of Islam from
among the Quraysh and the people of
Medina and those who may be under them
may join them and take part in wars in
their company interesting already is the
use of the term followers of Islam as
the term Islam as a designation for a
religion was according to many scholars
not in use until much later this
suggests that this section might have
been altered later or that the use of
the term has earlier origins than often
claimed it is also quite interesting
that the word Medina is used to refer to
the city rather than Yathrib which was
the word that was used at the time and
this also suggests that this section or
parts of this section may have been
edited at a later date the document then
continues to say they meaning the people
of this covenant shall constitute a
separate political unit Ummah as
distinguished from all the people of the
world now this is a significant line the
word Ummah is a very common word in the
Muslim world it is a word that's usually
used to refer to the larger cause a
Muslim community and thus almost
synonymous with Muslims today but here
it seems that the Ummah has a much
larger meaning and that it may even
include people who are non-muslims
living in this city other parts of the
text also do seem to suggest that anyone
who accepts this covenant and what is
laid down in this text is part of the
store shal unit or this Ummah and this
thus seems to include Jewish tribes as
well as those following the old pagan
legend it gives us a look into the early
history of a developing religion and a
time when the categories lines between
Muslim and Jew perhaps wasn't as clear
as it would be later on after all
muhammad saw his message as a
continuation or correction of the Jewish
and Christian religions and just maybe
that distinction wasn't that firmly
established yet nonetheless the
conception of umma as expressed in this
document do you suggest larger sort of
openness and tolerance than what is
perhaps expected in other parts of the
documents suggests similar things for
example and that those who will obey us
among the Jews will have help an
equality neither shall they be oppressed
nor will any help be given against them
and the Jews shall share with the
believers the expenses of war as so long
as they fight in conjunction and they
the Jews and the Muslims shall have each
other's help in the event of anyone
invading Yathrib in other words the
Jewish tribes as long as the accepted
Muhammad's rule was given completes our
problem entirely complete equality in
medinan society they also served in the
military together and were equally
responsible for protecting the city
related to this the later large
conquests of the Middle East and North
Africa often referred to as the Islamic
conquests also gets a bit turn on its
head once we realized that it seems that
Christians and Jews and maybe even
Zoroastrians served in that army because
of this many of argue that the term Arab
conquest is more accurate but we
shouldn't of course deny that the
emergence of Islam as a religion is a
huge deciding factor in this historical
event perhaps most telling for the
status of the Jews in Medinah is the
following and the jews of banu alf shall
be considered as one political community
umma along with the believers for the
jews their religion and for the muslims
there's again the idea of the jews being
part of this ummah is reinforced even
stronger ummah along with the believers
and the last line tells us something
about religious practice as well for the
jews their religion and for the muslims
there's this line gives us a look into
the way that religious differences were
dealt with in the city i would argue
that this does suggest a kind of
religious freedom the different tribes
are different
were free to practice their religion
again as long as the accepted Mohammed's
Authority one interpretation of this
then is that the proto state that was
being run in Medina was one in which
various tribes belonged to one political
unit and Ummah as expressed in this
documents under which there existed many
religious plurality of religious
traditions which all had at least
relative freedom another interpretation
of this is that the Jews constituted an
Ummah of themselves that existed
alongside the Muslims as the the quote
seems to suggest as well but not as part
of the same unit per se it's difficult
to know for sure exactly how this was
enforced at the time or how it should be
interpreted and thus there are many
views of it and has been has been
debated for many decades by now the text
never specifically mentions the Arabs
living in the city who follow the old
pagan tradition but certain lions seem
to suggest that at the very least they
lived in the city and undoubtedly pious
believers are the best and in the
rightest course and that no associate er
non-muslim subject shall give any
protection to the life and property of
Acorah sites nor shall they come in the
way of any believer in this matter the
word associated clearly refers to
polytheist is a common term used in in
Islam the cardinal sin of Islam is
sherek which the word itself means
association is associating God with with
some other God basically sort of
synonymous with polytheism I would
suggest that these people were also if
they choose to be so part of this
covenant in in this text and the valley
of yathreb Medina shall be a Haram a
sacred place for the people of this code
thus based on this it seems that even
the polytheist or some of them were
protected whether or not they were
allowed the same religious freedoms as
the Jews or other monotheists is of
course a very difficult question to
answer all of this points to a situation
that may appear surprising to many
people at least in the West it is
undeniable that this covenant or code
especially by the standards of that time
appears to be rather liberal or tolerant
of course we should be careful to use
such
in terms to describe the past in an
anachronistic way but if interpreted in
the way that I and some others have it
presents a picture of Islam or what
became Islam that challenge has many
preconceived notions that people have of
it in the Ummah in the constitution of
Medina Frederick M Denny says but the
Ummah of the Constitution is made up of
believers and Muslims and quite possibly
Jews as well although they may
constitute a separate Ummah alongside
the Constitution was very much a
political military document of agreement
designed to mega 3-band the peoples
connected with it safe and that kinship
was not the main binding tie of the
Ummah and the religion was of greater
importance indeed many of those who like
to criticize Islam often point to its
violent early history or certain Quranic
verses - to sort of justify of this
position certain Quranic verses like
those in surah 9 often referred to as
the sword verses and in which the
readers are encouraged to kill the
unbelievers wherever one sees them by
most Muslims these verses are understood
to be in the context of a battle and
thus only applicable in self-defense if
anything this document by the very fact
that Jews and other non-muslims had
certain rights and freedom of religion
and the pagans or polytheists lived in
the city shows that any reading of those
Quranic verses that is not bound by a
specific historical context appear to be
very historically inaccurate it must be
remembered that this is just one reading
or interpretation of this document some
have argued for example as I mentioned
that the Jew the Jews are not part of
the same room as the Muslims but a
separate OMA and there's another
question regarding why some of the major
Jewish tribes that lived in the city of
time isn't even mentioned in the
documents so what is the nature of their
relationship to Muhammad are they even
part of this document do they have the
same rights it's it's impossible to know
furthermore this of course isn't some
hippy peace document either it
constantly reaffirms the superiority of
the believers the Muslims and at some
times it has certain very harsh things
to say about the Quraysh tribe in Mecca
who were at war with Muhammad and his
followers the Quraysh should be given no
protection nor shall they who helped
them
it also lays down certain laws based on
Arabian customs and how punishments for
murder should be carried out including
payment to blood money and tribe
commitments with tribe relations all of
which is in accord with the time and
place in which it was written it makes
complete sense and it's a fascinating
look into 7th century Arabs of Arab
culture in itself aside from the fact
that is also a very interesting look
into the early Muslim movement so what
is so special about this document well
assuming that at least parts of it are
authentic it gives us a fascinating look
into an incredibly interesting and
significant historical period an
historical event and into the movement
that would develop into what we call
Islam it shows how the mission and
social message of Mohammed was one in
which the old social order primarily
based on different tribes and tribal
solidarity was to give way or at least
take a back seat to a more unified
social order one in which all was under
the rule of God and His Messenger and
parts of a unified Ummah it also shows
us that this Ummah in spite of being
ruled under God and the believers was
not one in which religious differences
was to be annihilated or assimilated
into the new faiths but instead a
political system that appears to open
for religious freedom and pluralism the
same tendency can be seen in later
Muslim empires or caliphs it's in which
the conquerors were not at all
interested in converting the people that
they conquered but just to rule over
them all of society was not to become a
Muslim but to be ruled by Muslims based
on this it appears that the Prophet
Mohammed was a very clever politician
and leader as he was able to unify a
people that were plagued by tribal
conflicts to create a nation that was so
strong that it was able to conquer large
portion of the world's after he died the
so-called constitution of Medina is a
significant document today many lips are
called liberal or progressive Muslims
and Muslim reformers generally tend to
use it as as a justification for arguing
that early Islam was open and tolerant
this is all interpretation of course as
is most that I have said in this video
but in spite of this it remains an
incredibly interesting document that
deserves to be read by anyone who's
interested in the subject have any of
you read this
and if so what is your interpretation of
it do you agree with me and other
scholars or do you have completely
different interpretation of what it
means and do you think that it even is
from the time of Muhammad or a later
fabrication for example I would love to
hear your opinion so please leave a
comment and we can continue this
discussion so I'll see you next time
[Music]